إنها محادثة مع واجهة الذكاء الاصطناعي
مثل دردشة GPT أو مقطع فيديو تم إنشاؤه بواسطة الكمبيوتر
يخبرنا بالأخبار، القفزات الأخيرة
في الذكاء الاصطناعي تمنح
البشر قوى جديدة للإبداع ولكن معها
تأتي مخاطر ومسؤوليات جديدة أيضًا،
على سبيل المثال، فقط
ألق نظرة على هذه  من الواضح الآن أن الصور المزيفة
لم يخرج البابا
ويرتدي سترة منتفخة وألق
نظرة على هذه الصورة بصفته الرئيس المؤدي
دونالد ترامب نعم تم القبض عليه ولكن
لا يبدو الأمر كذلك في هذه
النقطة، فهي تبدو حقيقية الآن الآن
يجادل الضيف بأننا على وشك رؤية
المزيد من هذا النوع من التزييف العميق الذي
تم إنشاؤه بدون مهارات خاصة أو
ميزانيات كبيرة وكلما رأينا أكثر، كلما زاد
ترددنا في أن نكون قادرين على
الوثوق بأي شيء، فهو مجرد جزء من
التحذير  من شخص مؤهل جيدًا
لإثارة المخاوف، أنا أتحدث عن إريك
شميدت، الرئيس التنفيذي السابق ورئيس
مجلس الإدارة لشركة Google، وهو الآن شارك في تأليف مقال
افتتاحي في المحيط الأطلسي والذي أوصي
بقراءته حيث يجادل بأن
الذكاء الاصطناعي لديه القدرة على
تضخيم كل شيء  من أسوأ جوانب
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ويدعو أيضًا إلى
خمسة إصلاحات للمساعدة في حماية
مجتمعاتنا وينضم إلي إريك شميدت الآن،
إريك عظيم لوجودك معنا، أنا
متحمس جدًا للتحدث معك حول
هذه النقطة التي أعتقد أنها نقطة البداية لـ
المحادثة هي أن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
كانت بالفعل سامة جدًا لمجتمعنا
إذا غطيت ذلك بقوة
الذكاء الاصطناعي فإنك تضخم
كل شيء، الطبيعة الإدمانية لها،
سمية المعلومات المضللة،
ومن السيئ
أنك على حق تمامًا، الخطأ الذي ارتكبناه منذ
15 عامًا  في السابق، لم نفهم
السلوك البشري، واعتقدنا أن كل شخص
في مجال التكنولوجيا، وكل شخص في العالم، كان نوعًا ما
مثل الأشخاص في مجال التكنولوجيا،
ويتصرفون بشكل جيد إلى حد ما في قواعد مجتمعنا
كأشخاص في مجال التكنولوجيا، إنها ليست الطريقة التي
يستخدم بها العالم الأشخاص الذين يعملون كثيرًا  هذه الأدوات للتضليل والتلاعب
للقيام
بأشياء أسوأ وسيزداد الأمر سوءًا
بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي، ستسمح لك
باستهداف الأشخاص بشكل فردي وجعلهم
يصدقون أشياء
خاطئة تمامًا وكليًا،
ستجعل الأمر أكثر إدمانًا في
حياتك  ضع في اعتبارك أن الأمر سيجعل الأمر أكثر
تلاعبًا وفي الواقع أحد
الأمثلة التي تستخدمها هو Tick Tock والشعبية
النسبية لـ Tick Tock هي في
الواقع منصة
تقوم بهذا بشكل أفضل في عقلك
اليوم جيدًا Tick Tock هو Tick Tock هو
جيدون بشكل خاص في الاستهداف أه بناءً
على اهتمامات الأشخاص وهم
يقومون بعمل جيد جدًا في ذلك،
والسؤال هو ما الذي يفعله
بعقول الشباب في مقالتنا نشير إلى
أنه لا يُسمح للشباب الذين تقل أعمارهم عن
16 عامًا  يفعلون
أشياء كثيرة في المجتمعات لأن أدمغتهم
ليست متطورة بشكل جيد ومع ذلك
لديهم إمكانية الوصول الكامل إلى كل شيء جيد أو
شرير يفعله كل شخص بالغ في
العالم بما في ذلك أشياء مثل المواد الإباحية
ومقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بالجرائم المروعة وأشياء
مثل هذه التي قد ترغب فيها  لا تريد أبدًا
طفلك المراهق وتشير البيانات إلى
أن الأمر سيء بشكل خاص بالنسبة للمراهقين في مرحلة ما قبل المراهقة
وخاصة للفتيات في مرحلة ما قبل المراهقة. هناك
الكثير والكثير من الأدلة التي تشير إلى
ضرورة وجود تنظيم حول سن
الوصول إلى هذا بالإضافة إلى بعض
الأشياء الأخرى مثل  حسنًا، سنعود إلى ذلك
لأنني
أعلم أن إحدى الطرق التي تريد
معالجة هذا الأمر بها هي الحديث عن رفع
سن البلوغ على الإنترنت إلى 16 عامًا
وإنفاذه فعليًا، وهو ما أعتقد أنه
ربما يكون النقطة الأقوى هنا ولكن
هناك نقطة أخرى  الزاوية أيضًا في
تحذيراتك وهي
أم تأثير
القيادة الاستبدادية حول العالم ما
يعادل تيك توك أه في الصين على سبيل
المثال وكيف يغمرون النظام
أه بالمعلومات الموالية للحكومة
قصة مماثلة مع روسيا حول
حرب أوكرانيا أيضًا السلطة  يعد
التأثير على السياسة في جميع أنحاء العالم
عاملاً مهمًا أيضًا،
لذا فإن ما تعلمته في إدارة YouTube
هو أن الأشياء التي يتم رؤيتها لا يمكن أن تكون
غير مرئية، وهذا ينطبق بشكل خاص على
الفيديو،
لذا عندما تنتج مقطع فيديو مزيفًا،
فسيحدث هذا كثيرًا في هذا التالي  قم
بتدوير تلك الانتخابات حتى لو أخبرت
الناس أنها مزيفة حتى لو عرفوا
قبل أن يشاهدوها أنها تغير
سلوكهم لأسباب لا
نفهمها تمامًا لذلك سأخبرك أن
الجميع جميع اللاعبين سواء كانوا
حكومات أو خصومنا أو
الشركات أو  ستقوم المصالح الخاصة
بإنتاج أشياء
تهدف إما إلى التلاعب
بنا أو تضليلنا باستخدام التكنولوجيا
المنتشرة على نطاق واسع جدًا، ومن
السهل للغاية استخدام هذه التكنولوجيا، ومن
السهل للغاية العثور عليها، وحقيقة
الأمر هي أن انتشار هذه
التكنولوجيا هو  تم إنجازه وهو
متاح عالميًا، ليس لديك أي فكرة
اليوم عمن صنع الفيديو والصورة
التي تشاهدها على إحدى منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
اليوم، أنت بصراحة لا
تعرف كيف يمكن أن يكون هذا جيدًا،
أعني ما يحدث في مجتمع حيث
أنت حرفيًا  لا تثق بأي شيء حيث لا
يمكن لأطفالك أن يثقوا بأي شيء،
نحن لا نعرف ما يحدث عندما يتم
التلاعب بسهولة بمنارات المجتمعات، وهي الحكم والثقافة وما إلى ذلك، في مقالتنا، وما
نقترحه هو أن هناك بعض
التعديلات البسيطة نسبيًا التي يمكن إجراؤها
تم ذلك وقبل أن نتحدث عن
التفاصيل، يجب أن أقول إن الذكاء الاصطناعي في حد ذاته يعد
إنجازًا استثنائيًا، حيث أن
تطوير طبيب الذكاء الاصطناعي ومدرس الذكاء الاصطناعي
وما إلى ذلك سيرفع
القدرات الاستخباراتية في جميع أنحاء
العالم، لذا من فضلك لا تسمع أن هذا يعد
بمثابة  سبب للتوقف أو أيًا كان علينا
التعامل مع الأمر عندما
ظهرت الكهرباء، أدرك الناس أن الأمر
خطير والحمد لله أنهم لم يوقفوا
الكهرباء، لقد اكتشفوا طريقة
للتعايش معها، سيتعين علينا
التعايش مع هذا الاختراع  هذه
التكنولوجيا القوية بشكل لا يصدق مع ما
أعتقد أنه بعض
التغييرات المعقولة في كيفية عمل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
عندما أتحدث مع القادة السياسيين حول
الذكاء الاصطناعي وهو ما أفعله يبدو أن
كل ما يريدون
التحدث عنه كل يوم هو وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي